Food shopping these days can be stressful but at holiday time, it can be especially rough.
Good Housekeeping has a few tips to keep you stress-free and organized,...
...like bringing your own reusable green bags.
If they become too bulky, place the smaller bags into the larger ones...
...then clip them onto the back of  the carriage.
If you're buying jugs of water or soda, put those in your carriage first...
...so you don't have to rearrange your cart to keep the bottles from crushing fragile purchases.
Another time and money saver, writing your grocery list at home.
The more you're in the store for over 30 minutes, you're more likely to spend more money.
So by making a list and sticking to it, you'll get through the grocery store faster...
...rather than wandering through the aisles.
Standing in line either at the deli counter or checking out is a real time waster.
See if your supermarket allows you to place your deli order over the phone.
Hello, I placed an order about 15 minutes ago?
Is that turkey and a roast beef that you ordered?
Yes.
OK, here you go.
And finally, simplify unpacking at home...
...by asking your grocery clerk at the store to group like items together.
I'm Terry Anzur for Good Housekeeping Reports.